ah yes the bee sting King in the Rat
King
[Music]
welcome to King and the sting
what's up brother what's up dude how you
doing man I'm doing good yeah yeah I'm
doing pretty good man
where were you this past weekend I was
uh which is the name of my other podcast
um I was in Omaha original name by the
way yeah thank you
yes I was in Omaha Nebraska
oh yeah we had a good time man it was uh
we had Anthony Smith came out the Lion
Heart the fighter oh the gentleman
fightin John Jones yeah light
heavyweight he's a badass dude when he
told me who's fighting John Jones I got
scared
you didn't know I know I had no idea I
started looking around for John she's
scary so I was nerve-racked but you know
he's got nothing to lose man no but a
picogram baby what is a picogram
steroids is it really yeah and that's
what John Jones had right it depends
what you do how you define a Pico bro
Pico Boulevard picogram I mean look I
used to do steroids by the interstate
didn't ya Pecos then oh I was p-code ups
yeah I bet you'd peacoat up right now
oh dude and we used to pull off my buddy
and he died actually ate a bunch of
pills and drove into an embankment
actually all right he Billy conforto
damn Billy yeah 45 year old homoerotic
busboy oh and uh who's your best friend
one of my best friends you know Wow
all yeah I'm not yeah whatever yeah dude
he took a bunch of pills and he never
even took advantage of me so so you know
I'm not a gang so you think I know bro
no you don't know dude I wouldn't know
in my heart if someone had taken
advantage of me no you wouldn't
cuz your brain deleted that [ __ ] off
your ass okay this is not an
interrogation brother no it's definitely
not
it is not welcome in the sting and why
don't we start the episode off with a
new segment
Tellem Brendan little rip my drip you've
seen the Oscars do it you've seen us do
it on E
well me not Theo you've seen us do it
though time to rip that drip yeah who
lifts we bro use E to lift weights you
steroids you idiot you
whose ham dude were you doing five
milligram let's get let's get deal on
this on this pedal stool up there let me
see what he's rocking with here this the
outfit of the day it is a lovely Tuesday
and field decide to wear this huh that's
yeah that's that's the style for a
Tuesday excuse me sir dude you look like
you carpool with your mom in a [ __ ]
Subaru Forester everyday you look like
you have churros in your pocket
what are you wearing brother what the
[ __ ] what are those pants dude those are
our lubricants those are what outdoors
as a for outdoors outdoors why they
pulled up like that huh that's how they
do you look like [ __ ] Baloo from
tailspin with those [ __ ] pants you
know you look like you just got fired
from Red Robin let's bring up let's
bring up Brin and sham here okay if you
can bring up Barry shop you look like
NASCAR arouses you yeah quit ripping my
drip bro I want to rip his drip was
throwing up on the brain you bring up
that stylish [ __ ] oh my god bro
what's up bro you look like the
strongest female figure skater I've ever
seen hey awesome peacoats huh on them
Pecos you look like obviously you sell a
cologne at a gas station okay dude you
look like that's been held back in every
grade you're 32 years old in high school
and you're still asking [ __ ]
sophomores for rides home though that
necklace t-that thing is so fake bro
fake dude I could buy your mom's trailer
with this thing like the ballerina
that's in a little girl's jewelry box
dude get your life together ah let's get
this episode going who's ready to King
under sting it let's do it first one we
have from Luis Chacon Chacon is Spanish
definitely Mexican reading Canelo the
Rat King and the bee sting gang gang
buzz-buzz see boys Luis from San Jose
as Buzzbee got a question for you king
it or sting it peeing in the shower you
know you're in the shower scrubbing
yourself up got to take a leak do you
pee or do you hold it to get out of the
shower so peeing in the shower
King it or string it Gang Gang buzzbuzz
buzzbuzz my Red Rocket friend huh buzz
buzz dude hold it to you get out of the
shower and then pee where in the sink
not like a psycho you [ __ ] let that
thing go like a super soaker oh and
here's a little fact for your athletes
out there if your feet inch you piss on
your feet and it gets rid of any
athlete's feet you know that okay first
of all that is something somebody made
up not probably it worked you know
there's a man laying in bed at probably
a gay man laying in bed somewhere just
imagine all these young athletes pissing
on their own yeah but you have a rasher
interface I will piss on your face you
want I'll do that for you oh you got
some definitely troubled growth on you
piss a couple grow that beard off dude
that beard loose
do I have to lighten it up bro we did
where'd you learn to grow a beard near
Chernobyl bro you can bury your noble
hair any hair on you got that yeah oh my
god yes oh you look like a go [ __ ] that
Erica you look like a Labrador that's
getting older in the chin bro act
together definitely [ __ ] King peeing
in the shower who holds it what kind of
[ __ ] circular holds it well not see
it people that better with the church
usually will hold it um if you're gonna
be in a storm if there's weather if
there's hard weather coming in do more
it's a [ __ ] in the tub you know that no
they don't that's and then they grade it
down like cheese no I'm dude I've seen
it happen for what my cousin's Mormon to
do what for wine no they do stop it like
grace but it's [ __ ] just to get it
through the the so there's no clock
you're a disgusting that's life welcome
to life do get out your goddamn trailer
park and experience life yeah you need
help Lewis I'm gonna say this brother
I'll piss on your feet if you're in a
fire dude I'd do anything for you my
friend I will [ __ ] in your tub if you
need it let's move on what else would I
say King it for sure definitely King it
that one's easy yeah that was easy one
next one from Danielle ferns
burns here from Vancouver Canada
currently down in New Zealand playing a
bit of rugby okay you posit the freckles
on freckles hey Danielle okay you want
to keep it going what's up his blue eyes
don't talk to my girl
dude that's my girl rewind I've got a
king understand for you
CrossFit girls I know Kalyn loves us
what do you guys think well counting
like two dudes too so that does count
yeah he likes what men and women here's
dude you got kissed by a bunch of
strawberries on that lady yeah okay wow
you're something else today I'll say
this young lady let me focus on the
issue at hand this young lady's from New
Zealand do you know where that is
I think she's visiting there cuz there's
no accent again get the [ __ ] out of your
house quit watching reruns of mash and
experience life she doesn't have an
accent she's an American in New Zealand
[ __ ] man did you did you just sleep in
when your mom's trying to home-school
you on New Zealand too - have you been
drinking
perfume me [ __ ] look horrible oh yeah
you got you drinking mouthwash enough
you look like Orville Redenbacher's
lesbian daughter dude okay
let me say this young lady here's my
issue with CrossFit girls they're good
girls
okay they're nice women the problem is
someone get pregnant and they continue
to do deadlifts sheer jack you know
[ __ ] uh you know wall killers and all
of this [ __ ] you know [ __ ] [ __ ] K
kurz and all it is whatever they're
doing you know these labia stompers
throughout they're doing all these
different things is dangerous you know
I'm not trying to be at the gym and step
on a damn zygote you know mm-hmm so a
lot of these ladies it's just like and
you can't tell they're between CrossFit
men and women they look the same that's
my problem - I'm with you on this my
biggest problem with CrossFit women is
their dicks you know I'm saying that's
the biggest problem yeah I don't know is
it a dude is it a girl you squat more
than me yeah then you run faster than me
yeah I don't like that dude
I saw a girl one time she had barrettes
in her and she [ __ ] just ate him as a
snack in the middle of her lift dude I
once thought damn this girl is [ __ ]
moving she's pretty hot tan skin braids
in her hair it was a black guy do your I
favor oh wow
yeah I could see that I thought look at
that Applebaum and then I felt guilty
for being attracted to him well I got
out the team alpha me yeah I would say
man I've seen some of those CrossFit
girls are dying me die Me's they can
hear that little backtracking bro no
they can dead ones they can deadlift
this dick in their mouth the actual like
competition ones who are jacking on for
record yeah [ __ ] get off my nut yeah
them I like the ones who like work out
have a few calluses on their hand but
doesn't it feel like [ __ ] you know
Tom Brady's jacking me off yeah I don't
want a girl who's not gonna jerk me off
because my dick doesn't weigh 40 pounds
a lot of these chicks I only want these
heavy dumb you know I'm saying yeah I
don't need you to get chalk out to jack
me off no I'm saying like I don't leave
ya I don't need you to a LeBron before
you freaking you know jack me off and I
don't need some of these gals that get
real strong in their vaginas get real
hearty they get harder to get thick well
yeah Mary tried to you know touch her
vagina in my hand and her clitoris
wanted a thumb wrestle blow the whistle
you know what I'm saying this wad is
done bro also workout of the day the
other day also I don't need some [ __ ]
doing [ __ ] burpees and drinking red
line she sucks me off that's the other
thing I bums me out yeah red line up
kill you man
there's no Cain in a bottle oh dude it's
four lokos for lesbians is what it is
yeah you right brah I'm gonna say I love
women that stay healthy but staying it
I'm staying it there's a little too
extreme for Wow you just follow whatever
I do yeah
[ __ ] you Danielle's not gonna be happy
about that nah she'll strawberry kiss
now
well she's underage so maybe quit talkin
real happy 21 or us seems like a nice
young woman who has a bright future
ahead of her well she's you thought she
was from New Zealand
yeah no she was American as [ __ ] yeah
cuz you're blind she said she's in New
Zealand dude
next one from idiots Chandler or [ __ ]
homeschool Chandler girl roar I'm
definitely definitely mine looks like
you spit on Game of Thrones Chandler
I'm from Slidell Louisiana shout out the
boot st. am I gonna sing it for you guys
another home school should guys shave
their ass crank
can't get a sting it let us know you he
apparently has some hairy anal
situations going on the promise here you
don't shave it what are you a [ __ ]
savage your wax it Luisi
oh wow save that [ __ ] son nah let me
get stubble and [ __ ] you and that's like
sandpaper walking your wife I've caught
the ball and booty wax they do yeah it's
the most common thing men do it's not it
was common oh man if you go to their
families true true
I'm saying your friend and you never get
that stuff removed it's called ball and
have you ever had it done I have it I
had my girl cuz I was thinking about it
cuz I do it you know he gets a little
hairy back there yeah a duck tail oh
yeah I got the little duck tail and so I
had my girl put just put a patch on the
inside of my leg was like let me just
feel it she was playing with a Nicorette
patch yeah kind of Nicorette pack size
yeah and she ripped it and then [ __ ]
hurt not for me dude not for now what a
wimp I'll tell you this if you want to
shave my ass dude you want to get down
there you want to use silverware
whatever you got to do 2d hair my ass
you're welcome to do it no no and I'm
from Louisiana bra don't you have a
[ __ ] like if you need to start a fire
one of these Malibu fires that killed a
bunch of rich people [ __ ] it started in
my ass crack son you know I'm saying I
got too much hair back there sometimes
it's like if I fart you can figure out
that at that yeah you know do not edit
me out you can hear I'll say this dude I
fart so now you can't even hear it
that's how much hair I have sometimes in
my butt yeah it's all your your silence
you here's a silencer oh yeah bro I got
that silencer all right so when I'll
grow a [ __ ] mitten I'll make a damn
cut that [ __ ] off four locks for lust or
whatever yeah you know if they ain't
even Seagal [ __ ] oh dude I got the
Arthur Ashe baby you know alright I got
that [ __ ] uh you know I'm Vladimir
Putin but you can't even hear him
no I'm saying alright
so really uh that elastic jungle from
guts I don't know it's just a bunch of
bungee cords that it's really hard to
navigate through it's a perfect analogy
don't worry about looking up later
so I say um yeah you gotta take care of
it so you're gonna King this yeah you
can't have somebody well you don't just
let anybody you don't know go back there
with scissors you got a lot of family
members no no you don't do scissors like
a goddamn Savage you use wax like a
gentleman and then you have that squeaky
clean [ __ ] like a GI Joe why thanks
laughs wax it up to you all right
sting shaving it yourself
I say King shaven yourself you're
talking to men who cut his own hair to
lose 27 and I'll you know what I'm
saying you give me a pair of uh I'll
even use those school scissors with the
with the rounded ends dude oh I can't
stab that [ __ ] it might take me two
hours in a funhouse mirror but I'm
[ __ ] giving my [ __ ] a haircut yeah
that's fun all right number four last
king at our sting it from Chase Stroud
that's a model bro okay that's nine oh
two one oh guys wearing short shorts at
the jam that's that kind of lazy susan
that guy kinda I think I have [ __ ]
hostages in this room why was he so
quiet and looking around like it was
very interesting you know yeah creeped
me out
it's Jamie cross I think actually you
just enjoy that Jamie cloths actually it
looks like an extra from 90210 or
Melrose Place or something she does like
he looks like all the characters from
90210 he does then and
I forget the theme song but that was no
bomb the Peach Pit bro that's what he's
called my [ __ ] before it took those
scissors to it you know the pen
yeah the sandbox baby I got that Jocko
willing I got that buzz cut back there
baby ready to fade it up oh 4:30 a.m.
[ __ ] wide awake dude sweating damn
bro yep
that the the pound bro oh I got that J
in the trade dude I got the ass of a
[ __ ] you know I got the ass of a home
school kid of a home school kid yeah
with encephalitis yeah whatever that is
what are we talking about
you wanted to know are in short shorts
at the gym like 1980s Michael Jordan's
John Stockton style I celebrate short
shorts beat for this reason they make
sense baggy shorts don't make sense when
boxers when you see a boxing ring has
baggy shorts on can't move in those
things when at the gym I get it people
are in a look but y'all flex them quads
have that sheiks out the back maybe even
a little nut slide out the front when
you're on the bench no one gives a [ __ ]
it's functional looks good
chicks actually did get more than the
bagger ones there's a tip for you [ __ ]
out there okay you so you just need to
get to a gym I don't give a [ __ ] what
you wear teal spandex
short shorts your mom's dress I don't
give a [ __ ]
just get a membership at 24-hour fitness
or Gold's Gym you are mean and show me
your [ __ ] and I'm not I'm not going
to a gym it's open 24 hours and people
are only there about 12 hours true
you're employing people [ __ ] yeah
wasting [ __ ] air conditioning just
bad idea
I'll say this brother short shorts look
I love the John Stockton if your Johnson
stocking you feel me worse you got that
[ __ ] big heater the hitter then dude
let that [ __ ] hang out you have that
tremor in your shirt sometimes I don't
you do shorts I just do the [ __ ] a
waistband only in this dick out the
bottom me two brothers you know that's
that American right that dick peerless
sale bro
Oh bro that's the [ __ ] that's the
devil's Egret you know and that's how
you got to do it brought an endangered
species called a devil t ba I called the
devil's t-bone look one of these days
somebody's gonna bomb California and New
York and the rest of us are gonna really
[ __ ] party you feel me uh yeah I guess
man so are you in the short shorts or
not
I'm gonna say king are you trying to
recruit Isis on the show now I don't
know what's going on here Isis bro
well doesn't sound like it sounds like
is there any favourable for it I have a
poster in my [ __ ] up well you're here
says different your [ __ ] haircut says
different I said here kale I think Isis
really yeah really you think Isis has
nice hair
nice no I think they have that here I
think I think I just has that great
clips cut your hair it looks like it is
filed a claim with the BP oil spill that
[ __ ] looks like it has a [ __ ] hurt
pigeon in it like an insurance claim get
your [ __ ] life together I'm gonna say
King it bro
the shorter the shorts the better I want
to see that [ __ ] cop me to get the
mass cheeks out the back king of sweet
that does it for this week's King under
sting it and we're switching it up this
week the next segment is gonna be
sweeping the nation flaunt my aunt Oh
get your mother-fucking on it's out and
he wanted Brendon wanted to call its
mother my brother dude and it was about
where they put cheese on a black guy
yeah brother
no no it's where you look at people's
siblings sorry
no pretty much I've read the wrong line
number one from Melissa lamb ELISA Lam
Melissa lamb well goddamn girl to get
those dimples huh hell yeah them deep
dimples them
heartbreak eyes done she oh she got she
got that Addams family vibe going on
that somebody's aunt from the 40s why is
it black and white well first of all
don't send your aunt in black and white
bro she has the skinniest neck ever and
some great teeth okay and eyes but she's
given Adams family vibe off that is a
very alarming the girth of the neck is
very alarming tiny little neck right
yeah they're almost should be some nuts
at the bottom of her neck it seems like
very alarming neck girth I will say this
it's almost like an ankle
r.i.p obviously this pictures from the
30s or something looks like about 20 1
then Y a beautiful lady deep dimples
though you know what I'm saying
deep deep dimple it's kind of I mean
those things definitely
he could pull a little bit of you know
you hide some ranch in those things Oh
you could definitely that's the oh those
are [ __ ] little dip in craters bro
nice teeth to eyes especially it for
teeth in the 30s that's [ __ ] good but
very small like Jedi getting to grow
with a small head bro
ah the worst I caught the Beetlejuice
head bro it was crazy sometimes when I
would kiss her I could almost put both
of my hands around oh no was she stupid
she's the brain the size of a [ __ ]
brontosaurus she was kind of smart no
well but I'm gonna say flow man what's
this lady's no no I'm sealing that so we
don't have the on snai mitts from Alyssa
they didn't have names back then that's
unfortunate no she's just female number
one aunt dolly aunt dolly dolly Hey okay
if we're gonna scent if you're gonna
flaunt you're not she can't be from the
20 no she can't bro in black and white
now she's a dime piece she's not piece
I'd like to know a story behind it I
died of typhoid brooch she died of
probably very rich bride died of the
Black Plague in the 20s dude they didn't
have the Black Plague nope your mom tore
that page out of your book in
homeschooling they did have it did they
really yeah what was it who was it there
was a bunch people had it really yep
bunch people died from it bro and it
could been that yeah they got it [ __ ]
rats [ __ ] that's her oh sorry bro not
the bees let's roll
number two sent in from whale Bret it's
his uncle Cameron oh gosh and that's
about that's alcoholism he's having a
stroke it looks like he's having a
stroke with his face looped down to the
side like that his neck super tight and
he's making a fist you know I'm saying
so it looks like he's in a little bit of
a struggle City but he seems like a good
guy he's indoors he there's a woman in
the background looks like she cares
about him or she's packing her [ __ ] up
but now it's a trailer park it's not
much yeah that's a trailer bro five ever
seen it looks very narrow woods on the
side there's an old school picture
behind it then he has a Christmas hat on
and only [ __ ] we're [ __ ]
sunglasses indoors
okay I'll agree with that this guy
obviously graduated I think from
limp sand or one of those schools you
think he seemed like a he's obviously
rushed TKE or some you know he looks
like a South Carolina Gamecock yeah he
does okay he's a Gamecock so he
definitely seems like he yeah he rushed
a fraternity has an open bottle of
champagne
indoors looks like he's wearing shorts
here's a woman in the distance with the
with a more manly haircut than am
definitely making food he looks like the
type dude has walnuts in his pocket
then the uncle walnut oh he definitely
looks like he looks like he gives the
shittiest Christmas gifts ever oh he'll
pull a couple of [ __ ] honey-roasted
out there's a couple honey roasted
[ __ ] almonds he looks like he'll give
you a blanket on your birthday yeah he's
that type of uncle he's married oh he
has on a wedding ring uh that's an T
floor in the back his his lovely wife
that's auntie flora so they're from
another country this guy could be
Duchess God does look dodgy you have
sunglasses on too cuz that's very
[ __ ] German Gary died aerodynamic
you're the Dutch are very aerodynamic
look at him next time German the Germans
are too though measure one cheek to the
other four and a half inches at most
just weather so fast Oh
downhill they call him the Dutch the
downhill people well what's his hat
service Masson the Hat and you he also
looks like he has one eyebrow uh and how
[ __ ] don't you have to be he honestly
even though he seems like a really great
guy now don't give to be to wear a Santa
hat in the right Christmas on the yeah
you know I don't we get it oh no I
thought it was from the [ __ ] summer
uncle adore where the [ __ ] your name is
yeah I thought you just wore a white hat
with a red top and a little white cotton
ball yeah then you put Christmas on me
cuz I thought you got in Jamaica you
[ __ ] let me see the air back no no woman
no cry no calendar
no cry this guy doesn't know one [ __ ]
oh she's making sloppy joes in the back
this switches everything up it looks
like Aunt Jemima back there make them
sloppy joes maybe a gingerbread cookie
of some sort yeah she has glasses on -
everyone wears glasses brother look at
the shittiest artwork of all time behind
them though Jesus Christ where iam you
idiot that's not Tom rip that page out
of the textbook - it's not aquarium you
[ __ ] you think a tank of water is out
and drawing you're an idiot that's a
trailer park he's having a stroke and
looks like the people in the back are
making sandwiches and don't give a [ __ ]
he's on a stroke they're making sloppy
joes he has one eyebrow that's it yeah
what else we got a [ __ ] this dude bro
Bob's your uncle bro I think he seems
like a great guy anything like an
outgoing guy but also man [ __ ]
because he has yeah Santa's Christmas
it's insulting it's insulting I think he
definitely gets too drunk at holidays
he's like fun uncle but then all of a
sudden people counted up and he's had
four bottles of wine today if your
uncle's wearing sunglasses indoors [ __ ]
off yeah your uncle [ __ ] your uncle
moet [ __ ] that dude
this is a Corey shawl he sent in his
lovely 75 year old mother
oh damn she dressed nice okay she look
like she's fresh off the Titanic
survivor Titanic survivor deal watch
your [ __ ] P's and Q's she went through
a lot oh I know she did man it's hard to
my thing would be I'd [ __ ] swim down
and steal some of the silverware I died
too broad go and get some that jewelry
for hell yeah I get that dumb diamonds
she looks like she got some of those
diamonds she looks Pleasant but she you
know what I don't know she was on
Titanic she looks more like she'd being
a submarine I guess submarine vibe from
her really yeah this kind of hole
captain's outfit could be Scientology I
don't know it's Scientology so just so
you know letters in there conjunctions
work but I'm gonna say this this lady is
wearing a shirt that has seven buttons
on the front well ones on button though
true but she obviously ain't giving out
a lot of that titty bread if you know
what I'm saying just cuff serving many
slices of that tbh no she has couple 1/2
graham cracker bread brother because if
you got seven buttons on your shirt who
the hell am i how many many getting your
shirt this [ __ ] do you think I am
Agatha Christie I'm gonna get your
[ __ ] shirt off cyclopædia buttons I
can't [ __ ] magic bro also a bunch of
books behind her a lot of books reading
so this lady obviously is kind of a
wordsmith or educated yeah so she's
obviously gonna tell you what she feels
about things looks like she binges on
Jeopardy and you have to pretend like
you care if you guys want to continue to
have a relationship yeah
you have a relationship with whatever
the [ __ ] say this you're gonna have to
graham crackers and watch tons of
jeopardy oh yeah well now sucked off
well and also she could not suck you off
if she wants to and just have a couple
of graham crackers because that gets old
night after night but I don't know they
have so many episodes of Jeopardy - you
couldn't watch them all before you died
it's on Netflix I think she's attractive
I'll say that she's an older lady and
that that doesn't look like a wig either
mm-hmm not even a wig brother no that's
real baby you know now that is a waik
iike grew out of for you if you if I
grew my butt hair out for about 14
months I bet I could [ __ ] it's that
gray oh I could sprout that top oh damn
yeah and she has a beautiful smile I'll
say this to her teeth - are those real
zoom in on them teeth zoom in on them
Chiclets from the 1600s now we'll say
this she also could be a vampire she is
in hock good point
she's in a library she's not looking
directly at the camera who knows if she
can see dude and is that real light
because usually vampires die in the
light that's a good for an interview
with the vampire right here ooh they do
look a little sharp and you know what
now look at it it's kind of creepy well
that posture [ __ ] her posture is too
good I don't know I like some posture
but you need a little bit of a hump yeah
I need a lady to slouch down near this
crotch once in a while yeah bro it's
like take it easy cuz she looks a little
uptight right now and this is to your
point vampire
yeah I throw a couple of quaaludes and
Grandma here you know what I'm saying
and take her out take her out for a
slice of pepperoni pizza
would you really yeah oh wow yeah
grandma's like that I probably stay at
the house and cook me up a couple slices
of that titty bread boy oh you tryin to
make some s'mores get the graham
crackers out in her tea oh that [ __ ]
french toast
sign oh all right that grandma's french
toast love it boy so I flaunt her she
looks like she makes the meanest
hashbrowns of all time I flaunt this
lady - I'm gonna say [ __ ] this lady
that's a fine young woman from the 1600s
dude nobody thinks you treat women well
so let's go to the next one that's
actually the last one for flaunt my aunt
it's debate club time
bro could you imagine if you and I were
in a contest for you mean like a
spelling bee
yeah I can she would get roasted how my
heart would be broken all the years she
puttin you in home school and you
[ __ ] fail the first one spell chair
Theo yeah
dude how many letters are in the
alphabet do you think if you had to
guess how many do you think huh how many
you think how much do you owe me tell
you I need to know how many your mom
told you I'm really 26
uh-uh she tell you 39 or did she tell
you
sevens 24 you or did she tell you 7 no
she didn't tell me 7 all right what do
you got debate club all right welcome to
debate club mmm that was your [ __ ]
in my throat
welcome to debate club now on this part
of the show we each get a buzzer so this
is what DJ DJ clue clue clue
that's that New York [ __ ] I flew this in
from DJ envy thank you really yeah bro
so you know who has that aggravating
don't [ __ ] touch me you idiot we need
a [ __ ] bigger table wider you know
whose buzzer that is not mine because
somebody sounds like they have been
smoking grams of Spring Break their
whole life yeah bro that MTV Spring
Break yeah there you go
[ __ ] yeah why don't you [ __ ] pulse
Carson Daly yeah Pauly Shore pull
steve-o out of your ass [ __ ] life
together I'm gonna say this right here
this is my buzzer so you know who means
business all right
and then our bike is so logic - from New
York there at the end just pick up the
Oh whatever the [ __ ] [ __ ] dude your
being is saddled up yeah hit it
[Music]
that [ __ ] is so fresh and then I do this
your buzzers the blockbuster buzzers
this is Netflix your buzzer sounds like
women are getting sexually abused in the
background okay yeah sounds like an
awesome time
it's true it depends on if you're in
international waters alright let's take
this to another level here let's see how
about debate club what's up what's the
first one from Samir D AB oh wow someone
is going on the old gang gang baby gang
Brendan your comedic [ __ ] savage buzz
but I got a quick debate for you guys
would you rather get stung in the mouth
by a wasp or a bee or would you rather
get bit on the dick by a rat
loving the show guys keep up the great
work looking forward to your debate
great work
yeah this guy ever been employed in his
life there's no it's gonna be considered
great work yeah it depends um I think
yeah
damn yeah well you're gonna have to side
with the [ __ ] rat I know the rats
that I work with the rats that I employ
don't bite people in the day
you pull their teeth out uh-huh pull
their teeth out no I don't let them gum
around somebody's [ __ ] either did also
how's the rack and get to your dick
that's besides the point you sure on the
streets and stuff rats get those San
Francisco rats are thirsty for dick oh
dude I was just there dude I was
offending rats off all day really all
day Oh sounds like my boys did their job
[ __ ] y'all rats I'll say this I'll go
with stung in the mouth by a bee just
because I mean yeah a rat really
thinking if you think about a rat it's a
mouse could get up your pant leg a rat
could but there's not there's a rat is
bigger so a rat isn't gonna be able to
get up your pant leg dude a rat can bite
through your shitty pants right into
your car if it has I can chew through
[ __ ] glass they can chew through wire
they can chew through houses glad you
Kate yourself on rats bro you're
supposed to be the Rat King
yeah glass rats are you know she's a rat
sure buddy rake into a bank huh
radio noise you idiot that's ha ha tails
right you you're [ __ ] right and take
the nature Channel this man I made it
you're out of your mind I'm gonna say
this
rats are they're not [ __ ] around with
some dudes dick we got bigger fish to
fry brother we have huge issues in the
world that rats are helping then you
haven't been in San Fran and rats are
the bees of the gutter bro bees they do
things they come over here they you know
pick up somebody's semen put it in a
flower rats do that [ __ ] on the DL in
the depths of the [ __ ] earth where it
matters most though the dark web animal
aren't they are they're the dark web
animal do that's are the dark web it
yeah animals dude there's Satan's
[ __ ] bumble bees and I'll say this as
well I [ __ ] sting a [ __ ] that's
what I think about this dude's
questioning bums me out
I'll take I'm gonna I would much rather
have a Hornet a or a bee sting the [ __ ]
out of my mouth then have a rat chew on
my [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah why don't you
[ __ ] go to a wedding in Tijuana duner
all right we've agreed I think we both
whether have a bee sting our mouth
rather look at bite off my head on my
dick right so do we even hit these
buzzers yeah might as well that's it
what else you got Jesus your buzzer
sucks
number two is from Daniel Schumacher
from buck snort Tennessee never heard of
it Oh buck snort a place oh yeah fake
place a great place to have your heart
stopped from huffing [ __ ] yay straight
up you're Snell what does he want to
know is that where your aunt from are
well I'm sure I got family and by story
dude
some printed view Connie from
at work I got a no seems scared hot
wheels or micromachines [ __ ] you please
settle it all right bye
don't [ __ ] touch me bro I got a new
job bro I need a new job if you go to
the bathroom asked a simple question
well suppose we help hot wheels and
macro machines I can't believe it's this
big of an issue in his life but I'll say
this
Thank You young fellow for submitting
the question get a new job though yeah
get a new job did you know hard you have
to go to those extremes - that just a so
simple question about Hot Wheels or
Micro Machines I think you works in
North Korea
yeah or tight just tighten up your
overall experience with the world
because it seem like you don't know that
you can just ask questions anywhere else
yeah tighten up in life yeah yeah but
that being said now with that being said
as a kid I mean you played with rocks
and [ __ ] empty cans yeah as a kid
like me out all the micro machines did
you all the micro machines yeah now look
you're gonna now a big idiot with a
bunch of little cars dude you played
with rocks and dead batteries so take a
hike when we're talking about toys yeah
I couldn't afford them but ya live
batteries you idiot and a lot of rot and
some of those rocks were geodes and also
have value
well you idiot whatever dude this one's
pretty easy Micro Machines / Hot Wheels
there's more detail we [ __ ] detailed
and they don't make them anymore yeah
cuz they went out of business cuz about
eleven kids choked to death okay
tiny you choke I'm talking about a real
toy that Hot Wheel something you could
get you know I'm saying you could roll
up bits right through some dog [ __ ] if
you found some in New York and you
understand how well you could slide that
thing across the counter new we keep
going yeah dude the Hot Wheels nice some
of the nicest cars in our neighborhood
we're [ __ ] Hot Wheels and I'll say
this dude a Hot Wheel I mean you could
sleep with a hot wheel in your bed a mic
machine you wake up you're [ __ ] your
little cousin's dead yes in your neck
it's in your ear oh I think you lose it
in your [ __ ] well tiny bro you don't
do anything like that but I will say
this is a true story I once heard that
John Mayer used to put micromachine cars
into Jessica Simpson's but that's
wow that makes them so much cooler yeah
that means back to you
it always comes around that Mac deal
they doing Stevie Wonder
man why no more dream and I'm just
disgusted yeah well I didn't get the
Russkies out of [ __ ] beer early Jesus
okay now all this have a white Erebus
you really a 80 year old bro yeah you're
a freakin Dumbledore what was the
question
Oh Michael I'm gonna side with deal on
this Hot Wheels there you go give it up
boy suite number three from Leon Walken
brother alright big bumblebee burning
shop since getting my shirt when Theo
came through the Lexington we talked
about giving me an asset to disabled
kids but I was just wondering we did
know you did personally think Shawn
Michaels cuz that [ __ ] Super
Kick Gang Gang hope y'all come to
Lexington soon I was just in Lexington
and yes I did remember that guy was in
the front row and he was on drugs and um
and he seemed like a nice guy and you
were talking about different acid
disabled people good hell that's go deal
I said some drugs could help some people
who have mental disabilities open their
mind yes alright no problem with that
open mine who shot me he said there was
a kid with autism down the street he was
trying to [ __ ] sneak a hit of acid
into his but I'm like that's different
than what I'm thinking of yeah that's
not what I was going brother good to see
you man but no finish [ __ ] Bret
Michaels or uh what was it Bret Michaels
or who Bret Hart or Shawn Michaels oh
dude
Shawn Michaels dude first of all you the
tits on him there Shawn Michaels uh sang
[Music]
one of the best songs ever
oh cool Diddy fantastic yeah dude Bret
the Hitman [ __ ] heart some say he's
the best wrestler of all time fell off
the [ __ ] Superdome and broke his back
so well first of all his brother fell
off and died you [ __ ]
for reals died I'm sorry [ __ ] the
other thing is is Bret the Hitman Hart
runs Calgary and I went up there for
comedy I had to get really the okay from
Bret the Hitman Hart to even come into
his goddamn City
really runs I love Calgary yeah no don't
backtrack now so then he gets to my
Calgary show all sweats didn't dress up
kind of piss me off right does he still
look pretty healthy yeah
pretty healthy had a dimepiece girl
dating yeah super dimepiece kind of his
handler cos he was a little bit out of
it
yes but that's an eight-piece in
exchange rate yeah but then he came in
the back and told my brother the longest
stories of all time and when engaged
with anybody else
very awkward I think he's attractive of
my brother okay well I'll say this dude
Bret the Hitman Hart did you look like
you used to do roids or not ah yeah man
because it's WWE look at [ __ ] Bret
Michaels pictured he that dudes on all
the picograms I'll say this dude Bret
Michaels I love that movie rock a love
have you seen that or bus rock buckle of
Heroes oh do I like yeah but that's not
[ __ ] him dude that's not him for
God's sakes you're thinking of the
musician on rock love great show and I
like the reference yeah rather [ __ ]
touch me and then this is Shawn Michaels
when the greatest rest was all okay I'm
thinking of the different rock when he
dated that girl diamond or what was that
other girl that stripper come out come
out nicolai think about who's yeah she
was good name but she would always poop
in her buddy's yard I'm gonna say this
man this the man you're talking about
right here yeah beautiful hair Shawn
Michaels is his name yes sir
I like can't break kid I like him
they're both legends yeah I'll give in
cuz I don't even know Bret Hart bro yeah
Brett Brett Brett Brett calgary's finest
finest finest good I think Brett
Michaels won that round yeah he was duty
he [ __ ] made hit songs then he wore a
bandana and and 39 without a bandana
fault he [ __ ] all them girls on rocky
first of all [ __ ] all of them which i
celebrated but then what's his
famous most famous song every rose has
its own yeah
every song dude why do you close your
eyes like Stevie Wonder he doesn't seem
like because I have soul you idiot oh
you don't your eyes it's just laughing
yeah Tourette's is basically soul and
disguise you you don't know anything
about science can we get something else
please because I can't say [ __ ] about
the world the last one from Jackie
child's Oh an Asian what a bee-sting
King and the Rat King I got a question
for you guys
this one's an honor of Brendan Schaub
for being a great male model
thanks bro street fighter buzz buzz or
Mortal Kombat oh [ __ ] one's better oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] dislike debating LeBron
James and Michael Jordan two of the
greatest video games of all time and as
a kid my daycare was video games really
yeah I know you used to watch from the
windows cuz you couldn't you know what
you can just play them yeah you have
money in the arcade yeah that was my
daycare bro and I [ __ ] love Mortal
Kombat Mortal dude
sub-zero scorpion people have hooroo
yeah people had electricity in their
hands that's a lie okay first of all
Street Fighter people there are actually
fighting in a place where you can learn
something streets people are different
ethnicities they had China's do grommet
just in LA Street Fighter was right has
green only Asians with suddenly in E
Honda and Ryu and Ken they were supposed
to I you supposed to be Japan Jackie
that's Asian you well he go holla Dukan
but he was white as [ __ ] yeah because he
and they look for the same he
transferred you freak
and then how about God family moved
their guile guile the American the
goddamn American yeah you and him
dressed very similar well guile
obviously has style and I'll say this
that the what about the green animal
they let hang out with them with the guy
the veggies of Baraka
yeah Barack Obama yeah Barack Obama
whatever that guy's name was and they
also had the black guy who could
levitate
oh is that are you talking about the the
yoga the Yankee yes dhalsim dhalsim
dhalsim and then I also had the the
boxer that was really Mike Tyson [ __ ]
what do you mean oh ho let me see the
whole [ __ ] roster cuz Mortal Kombat
brought the dude Zangief the Russian spy
yeah he was dope Zhang chun-li he honda
ryu chun-li hey my buddy
guile my buddy in her [ __ ] Zangief
looks like a pop off in that ass dude
wreck-it Ralph heard as honestly [ __ ]
dudes breath
oh dude that's right Zangief was in
wreck-it Ralph give it up dude give it
up Bravo Z yeah don't [ __ ] touch me
I'm not touching you uh who else did
they have huh who cares dude you've
named nothing about Mortal Kombat
obviously even and so Mortal Kombat you
got guru you got score don't we know
young z0
you got Sonia you got how about finish
him so finish it works at the door Oh
reptile so when your blade Sonia that
works at marble haha Jaffrey Kintaro
all right how about but how about the
finishing moves finish him you got hung
wow you got Cosmo the lizard dude the
time lizard dude the guy we used to buy
drugs from a nice dude I'll pay this
nose holt about Johnny Cage
how about Raiden was racist ray didn't
look like chin and it was [ __ ] up I
thought the entire time he's from Korea
no Izzy or is that just a stereotype who
knows me exactly you know I show up zero
that's it is horrible look at this
outfit dude it's it's mocking its mom
yeah look like yeah yeah look like
Chinese people from space looks like Big
Trouble in Little China yeah I quit this
man yeah you know I'm gonna go Street
Fighter there you go submit some miss
young finish him yeah get over here yeah
it's how you met your wife it sounds
like bro you got a pretty get over yeah
you need to go to some places and really
get some help dude yeah yeah one I I
think you want to convince me and Street
Fighter Mortal Kombat I was a hardcore
Mortal Kombat fan and he did it were you
thank you brother and at the close today
I want to say that you know I know we
rip each other a lot in this place
because Brennan deserves it and he would
never hear any
truth about himself if he didn't listen
to someone who knows stuff like me who
can't read so doesn't bother me yeah you
don't know what reading is do you think
it's you stealing a taboo steal color
and your off time you'd use coloring
books so doesn't bother me yeah you
thought that we're stupid two rivers in
the world correct the Nile in the
Colorado because that's all that
mattered all right sure guy you don't
know about aquifers or and you thought
cuz she said I'm in New Zealand she's
from there yeah and it was a white girl
with freckles everywhere yeah we traded
her bro know what I'm trading hmm well
look what I'm trying to do here or a 30
seconds I'm gonna say something nice
about Brennan as we close out the show
today so my 30 seconds starts now
brennan san you see my my name bro okay
sorry
Barry you seem out my name bro
okay Burtis nominee row okay Brandon
Chow nope I'm gonna salt all right go
you seem like a decent guy I'm done oh
wow okay thirty Seconds
no that's my turn DJ Rat King racking
you seem like the type of dude who would
rent a van and give kids rides after
school and I can approve that and I
think it's nice of you thank you you
also smell like hummus in-studio so
that's nice as well it's a snack yep
namaste you are snacky and I'll say this
is all brand
um about BS over here that uh he's
probably one of the top 60 or 70 people
I've met in the past couple years he is
he lives locally he you know if you talk
to him he can talk and he you know he's
very outgoing I'll say that oh I like
that my turn the one thing we opted do
his initials are TV that's kind of cool
so his friends call him TV yep yeah
that's probably the best thing about you
and his our BS dude yes bro so
call him [ __ ] yeah and there's TV
yeah
way better than yours dude he shouldn't
have started this argument bro
well this isn't arguing I was giving you
a compliment you weren't [ __ ] your
[ __ ] idiot [ __ ] idiot I'm gonna
leave I gotta be somewhere else anyway
yeah get the [ __ ] out I am I'm trying to
leave I think you guys for watching
send your submissions to the link in the
YouTube description you guys are killing
it for us the show doesn't happen
without the fans and their submissions
with flaunt your art and if you won't be
featuring winning again
dang gang buzz buzz buzz buck if you
want to be featured on rip your drip go
ahead and post that outfit of the day
let me in teal peep it out yeah
sent in something if you wearing
something nice are you doing something
you headed to a special event funeral
birthday party outdoors indoors but it's
fun yeah something do something and
let's go to the movies does a picture
outfit yes I tell you what we think
maybe on a big date you want us to give
you some help
send it in bro yeah that's my drip also
Flint you're not don't send any more
pictures from the 50s that's not fun for
us sentence Theo's looking for a date
and she's dead it doesn't work send in
some real legit [ __ ] and dudes for
him you don't care tell him bro um Bella
bro okay first up we'll do well now will
allow women and gay men or bisexual man
oh I don't think we should go to all the
way to flaunt my aunt as a man not me
neither
so and good luck to Anthony Smith out
there yeah he don't fight for a while so
makes zero sense and let's end with your
stupid-ass comics they don't fight for
weeks okay but let's wish them luck
anyways you think weeks is a long while
we're talking months we're talking
months bro in love do is just your
hair's gonna be down to your ass craft
that's a long time for you oh my god you
know the file under John Callender mom
just everyday put monday you should want
to bum you out that's it this is the
sting of the key
[Music]